hi oh this lighting does not look good
that's better today we're going to be
unboxing something extremely exciting
I know the whole hoverboard phase has
come and gone but I'm still not over it
yeah I'm sure you guys heard in the news
about the hoverboards catching on fire
and all this and that and all the
craziness well this hoverboard is by
Segway in Segway is one of the companies
that originally kind of patented this
whole technology of hoverboard Ness so I
actually already know what is inside his
box because the day that I saw these
came out I tweeted something about it
and then everyone sent me links to loo
from unbox therapy's video of him on
boxing it's when I watched it and I know
what's gonna happen so if you've seen
his video then this is really not that
exciting but what Lou doesn't have at
least I don't think he does is a team of
a lure knife I don't have much daylight
left and I want to get some outside
shots oh shoot I hope it's charged oh
sure please read first directions quick
start it alright
my old boy this is heavy what is this
this is such better quality than any of
the actual hoverboards that have been
out because they are all basically
garbage I should probably just turn it
on right let me download the app first G
oh boy that was scary I think I'm gonna
turn it on oh oh wow okay it's going
it's moving forward okay laughs okay it
looks like we've got full battery which
means ahead and out tonight
search for does dice I'm searching for
the device turn around let show us your
butt so you can control this with your
iPhone app you're by the way like I'm
doing this with my with me up it's
moving okay come come back forward oh oh
oh hello I think I should just step on
it oh boy yeah okay all right I think I
need to lift this up a little here so to
turn this is the steering wheel hi dog
how are you stop eating things you have
to stop this
are we going to ride I put a helmet on
because I was terrified so before you
actually can ride this it makes you do a
tutorial and a setup and all of these
crazy safety precautions which is pretty
smart
do the other hoverboards didn't do was
any of that so if you'll see here this
is how you turn this is a steering wheel
this steered unlike hoverboards where
you actually use your feet to turn you
stay completely stationary and just use
your knees to turn we like that you
don't know yet cuz I don't watch you
ride it yeah yeah I can I ride it I'll
watch you don't worry but it's tech
Tuesday so you're the main attraction
here
let's check your news day ride
my name it
there's a non-political watch s I don't
have to do anything I can just use this
and it grabs for me
I'll just step up to you good enough for
you okay I just saw the picture that
Jenna took of me I look like an absolute
idiot like what am i wearing I didn't
even know I was wearing this I match
this way
make it blue for boy I did look
turn around give us a nice spin Brian
okay oh oh oh there we go yay barb my
lights there blue headlight brake light
monochrome no one I can't do anything
colorful meteor
it also has a little handle so you could
walk it hey why is it beeping at me it
looks like I didn't end up ending this
video but I just want to give you a
quick little recap of what I think of
this ninebot Segway
this one far surpasses any one that I
ever tried the huge difference between
this and the other hoverboards is that
you don't actually use your feet to turn
so this makes a big difference in the
riding style and how you can really
actually maneuver it because you do use
the steering wheel and you use your
knees to turn so it took a little bit of
getting used to there's also a ton of
safety precautions so you basically have
to go through this tutorial before ou
unlock a faster speed so to show you how
to turn it'll show you how to use like a
little candle and it goes through all of
these steps before it actually allows
you to unlock its full potential I'll
put a link in the description where you
guys can get more information about it
this wasn't sponsored I bought this I
loved it and I'm gonna probably go ride
it again soon this is going to be the
best thing ever
for hatching eggs and Pokemon go today
we're going to be making banana
popsicles and I chose banana because the
only color on Amazon that I saw that I
could get same-day was a yellow popsicle
stick mold